[Musique]
sensation sensation le mag bonjour à
tous bienvenue sur sensation en
association avec TV 78 je suis
aujourd'hui avec Élise Tassin
responsable des partenariats du mécénat
du maison Lafitte Jazz Festival qui aura
lieu les du 16 au 25 juin prochain
bonjour bonjour Jessie alors cette année
c'est la 19e édition de ce festival quel
est son histoire et pourquoi valoriser
un festival à Maisons-Laffitte et bien
Maisons-Laffitte estivale existe depuis
2005 et suivi par un public
vraiment de fans et de passionnés de
jazz on a vraiment la chance d'avoir un
public fidèle et chaleureux qui nous
accueille chaque année dans un cadre
somptueux qui est le parc du château de
Maisons-Laffitte et qui se prête
spécialement au concert en plein air et
au concert de jazz et également
l'ancienne ancienne église de
Maisons-Laffitte qui a une acoustique
absolument exceptionnelle le jazz n'est
plus autant réputé qu'à une certaine
époque et pourtant les festivals de jazz
continua à intéresser de nombreux
citoyens pourquoi festival de jazz et
bien tout à fait parce que en fait tout
simplement la musique jazz est une
musique qui se vit vraiment sur scène
c'est une musique créative qui est
vraiment propice aux échanges entre les
artistes entre les musiciens et avec le
public il y a pas deux concerts de jazz
qui se ressemblent on est vraiment sur
des soirées exceptionnelles et voilà
donc le jazz est vraiment encore voilà
une musique très vivante sur scène avant
de parler de la programmation quelles
sont les maîtres mots justement pour
pour ce festival alors
les maîtres mots pour cette année je
dirais que c'est vraiment la virtuosité
la
chaleur du public et puis toujours
une découverte de la nouvelle scène ça
c'est essentiel pour le programmateur
Samuel struck et aussi toujours des
artistes internationaux très réputés qui
sont attendus avec impatience
et toujours une part belle à la création
également des concerts qui très souvent
sont en première mondiale au festival de
Maisons-Laffitte on va parler justement
de la programmation qui commence et qui
alors qu'ils commencent le 16 juin et
qui s'étend jusqu'au 25 juin on commence
avec Julien Loureau et Wayne's Wonder le
16 juin qu'est-ce qui attend le public
pour cette soirée et oui donc c'est une
soirée en hommage
les gens du jazz wants shorter qui nous
a quitté donc en mars dernier Julien
Louroux avait déjà préparé ce projet et
donc il était naturel pour nous de le
présenter en ouverture du festival
et c'est une vraiment une belle soirée
en perspective avec Julien Loureau qui
est déjà venu sur le festival et qui
d'une sensibilité extraordinaire donc
voilà une belle soirée en perspective et
le 10 souhaite juin deux concerts sont
prévus le premier est à 19h avec Kid kit
bigd on va on va écouter justement un
extrait on poursuit juste après
[Musique]
donc le 17 juin à 19h et à 21h une
artiste qui s'est déjà produite
plusieurs fois dans les Yvelines c'est
Sophie allour pourquoi la programmer
pour le maison de jazz festivalour et
donc artiste instrumental aux Victoires
du Jazz en 2022 c'est une artiste
absolument incontournable elle présente
un son dernier album avec père chaud à
la guitare Anne passée où est la
batterie et
Paul Collomb au violoncelle c'est un
très beau projet qui a lequel nous
présente sur le festival il était bien
sûr incontournable de l'invité cette
année c'est exactement un projet une
question c'était incontournable
incontournable pardon d'avoir Sophie à
lourd sur sur ce genre de festival le 18
juin deux concert également Ben turry et
lococello que nous réserve cette soirée
alors bentoury donc c'est vraiment une
soirée sous sous l'image de la
virtuosité benturi est un pianiste
vraiment époustouflant à la fois
et joueur de d'harmonica donc c'est
vraiment voilà un grand grand artiste
que nous recevons sur scène ce soir là
suivi de Loco de cello qui est aussi un
groupe assez unique ils ont sorti leur
dernier album en février porté par
François Salk notamment au violoncelle
c'est un artiste très connu en France à
l'international et il propose un
répertoire entre le jazz les musiques du
monde et la musique classique donc c'est
vraiment à découvrir sur la scène de
Maisons-Laffitte Jazz Festival et le 20
juin c'est l'artiste Baptiste Herbin qui
sera présent au festival on va écouter
un extrait on poursuit juste après
[Musique]
on a vu Baptiste Herbin est un petit peu
différent de billes de kit Biggy
de partout
le jazz justement c'est malgré tout des
ambiances différentes
à la fois du jazz vocal du jazz latinja
jazz manouche on a vraiment du bebop
boogie-woogie on a énormément de jazz
différents et donc c'est toujours la
promesse de découverte de voyage à la
fois et voyage dans le temps et donc
c'est toujours une programmation très
riche qui est proposée à
Maisons-Laffitte festival et le 22 juin
deux concerts également ha de Lopez
Nussa trio et influence et Louis
Martinez mais quel est le programme
justement de de cette de cette soirée
quels sont les univers musicaux de ces
artistes alors les univers en fait donc
pour
nous avons en première partie donc
Harry lopez-nous ça qui va nous
présenter donc une soirée vraiment c'est
latine jazz il vient de signer
d'ailleurs son dernier album sur le
label Blue Note donc c'est vraiment en
concert à ne pas manquer et Louis
Martinez voilà c'est aussi voilà un très
très beau concert sur sur des notes
voilà
qui sont
qui invitent au voyage qui invitent
voilà au partage donc une fois une
ambiance une ambiance différente
et quel est le programme pour la soirée
du 23 juin alors le 23 juin donc c'est
on commence avec un trio le trio
Aquarella au Bauman
tout Nico qui donc est un festival est
un pardon un concert autour des des
rythmes brésiliens très beau concert en
perspective suivi de la première soirée
événement du festival qui est un une
soirée dédiée en hommage à Django
Reinhardt donc nous aurons la joie
d'accueillir Biréli la graine grand
guitariste manouche sur scène
accompagnée d'Adrien moignart à la
guitare de Diego Imbert à la contrebasse
d'André secarelli à la batterie et on a
aussi Mathias Guéry au violon accompagné
par l'Orchestre National l'Île-de-France
donc c'est pas moins de 50 musiciens que
de vous aurons sur scène ce soir là
dirigé par Samuel strouck donc une très
très belle soirée hommage dans toujours
le parc du château de Maisons-Laffitte
alors le 24 juin ça sera miles Sanco qui
sera sur la scène de du Maisons-Laffitte
Jazz Festival et le 25 juin ce sera donc
la dernière journée du festival vous
clôturer festival avec le collectif
Paris swing à 19h et à 21h Fred Wesley
and the new JBS alors qu'est-ce qui nous
attend aussi pour cette dernière soirée
alors pour fast Wesley c'est tout
simplement le tromboniste de James Brown
donc voilà c'est une légende du jazz que
nous aurons à Maison-Laffitte donc c'est
un jazz entre voilà la funk et le et
maintenant teinté de plus de jazz et
c'est un voilà c'est c'est un grand
artiste à découvrir sur scène pour ceux
qui l'ont qui l'ont qui n'ont pas encore
vu et melsanko voilà une voix absolument
dingue entre Barry White et Marvin gay
que nous avons eu la joie d'accueillir
en 2018 et qui revient vraiment pour
pour notre plus grand plaisir et donc
c'est du 16 au 25 juin le
Maisons-Laffitte Jazz Festival pour plus
d'informations on peut se rendre sur
votre page Facebook Maisons-Laffitte
Jazz Festival tout simplement ou sur le
site ml jazz festival.com pour retrouver
notamment plus d'infos et la billetterie
merci beaucoup Elise merci d'avoir été
avec nous donc sur sensation je rappelle
que vous êtes responsable des
partenariats et du mécénat et pour
revoir ou réécouter cette émission
rendez-vous sur notre site et notre
application radio sensation
[Musique]